as tension runs high for a potential
missile test from North Korea president
Trump is in Florida this morning Errol
Barnett is in Palm Beach with more Errol
good morning good morning president
Trump is watching the North Korea
situation closely as he spends the
Easter weekend at his favorite Florida
retreat and even though there are no
public events on mr. Trump schedule
today and tomorrow he is sending a clear
message that he is willing to use
military force when necessary many are
seeing this as a clear departure from
his America first message as a candidate
we're very very proud of our military
president Trump said Thursday giving his
military commanders total authorization
is returning positive results there was
another successful event mr. Trump is
referring to the first ever use in
combat of the US military's mother of
all bombs US Central Command says the
more than 21,000 pound weapon killed 36
Isis fighters in Afghanistan dismantled
a network of caves and did not injure
any civilians it adds another country to
the list of places the US military hit
in the trump administration's first
three months and shapes what is becoming
Trump's foreign policy doctrine dead
children there can't be a worse site and
it shouldn't be allowed on Wednesday
President Trump praised the military for
firing 59 Tomahawk missiles at a Syrian
Air Field which served as the staging
ground for a chemical attack on
civilians I have absolutely no doubt we
did the right thing it is a stark change
from Trump's worldview during the
campaign we cannot be the policeman of
the world the president is also
exploring the benefits of more
diplomatic language while standing next
to NATO's secretary-general Trump
acknowledged his changing views on the
North Atlantic Alliance I said it was
absolute it's no longer obsolete in a
move that breaks with tradition the
Trump administration said it will not
release White House visitor logs in a
statement Friday the White House said
hundreds of thousands of people visit
the president's home every year
and releasing the logs poses grave
national security risks and privacy
concerns although the logs can be
requested five years after President
Trump leaves office and there's been one
other shift after mr. Trump repeatedly
promised to label China a currency
manipulator as president the White House
now says that won't happen after Chinese
President Xi Jinping and mr. Trump met
here at mar-a-lago last week Alex Errol
Barnett and Palm Beach thanks Errol